[Music]
you love motorcycles in real life you've
got motor sight yeah yeah a big part of
your life and what's nice is that's now
become another job for you in addition
to the walking dead you've got a reality
show where you pretty much we're
following you riding motorcycle and
you're hanging out people that ride
motorcycles yeah did describe the sort
of it was first of all this idea had to
come from you right it did not it came
from Joel still Irwin he's at AMC's the
head of original programming and he
called me up and he said I had got an
idea for a show and I went yes like
before you change your mind yes yes yes
right but it you know it's it's it's
been a blast shooting that like I'm
learning new things as I go along and
meeting really interesting people and
learning a lot about myself and about
whichever guess it's great you know what
I was interested in as I saw an ad for
the show a print ad that for ride your
show and this is you and I I didn't
understand I didn't understand how this
was advertised I think with this Jeff
what's going on here was that a
spontaneous moment or do they tell you
drop your pants it's got a photo well I
mean sometimes you get wrapped up in the
moment you forget there's a bunch of
cameras and stuff and I it was so hot in
Death Valley and we were on dirt bikes
and I just I had to like let some areas
breathe it was really hot yeah so I just
like got the full helmet on you got the
leathers you got the you probably got
the body armor and then you decided yeah
down below hot hot down there
yeah I'm constantly hot down there this
one I think problem good sorry on this
show I'm an idiot
you